i am thrilled to say we follow this
man's
fantastic television and radio simulcast
without which
we would not be here sitting in the
studio on the campus of at t as we still
are
he is my longtime friend colleague and
uh compadre
once again back to back uh with the rich
eisen show of the host of the dan
patrick show dp
dan patrick how are you dp
i'm great i'm great rich thank you for
the introduction please that's the only
way i know how to do it i only know one
speed dp
well thank you oh you bet uh how's life
everything good up there
in connecticut everything fine and dandy
yeah yeah we're trying to trying to stay
non-essential
and uh we're doing a pretty good job
oh my gosh so uh who's the best team in
the nfl right now dp
if you had to choose one anoint them if
you will you would choose which one
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with baltimore
right now
i i still think offensively defensively
they might be the
the most balanced team but i mean it's
so fluid it's day to day i mean it's
almost it feels like hour to hour when
you're watching on sunday or monday but
i i would probably do baltimore
but it feels like there's and i was
wondering about this how many teams do
you think
legitimately could win the super bowl
this year not
boy they got you know like the bears
they're not going to win the super bowl
okay you said spoiler alert no no i
guess you're
not you know that no i know i mean you
don't believe in the saint nick uh
run here huh you don't think there's a
magic carpet ride
in chicago well
the d i think they're a playoff team i
don't think they're going to win the
super bowl but if i
but it's weird if i say tampa is one of
those teams that can win the super bowl
well then the bears can win the super
bowl because they beat tampa if you're
using that logic but
i i was trying to think you got trust in
the rams of the niners right now
to go on a run um
you know what i i i i guess i'm picking
up what you're you're putting down right
here but if
if either one of them gets in if you
will the dance don't you think either
one of them could go on a run
for to to win it dan
i don't i don't know if they're that
cons i think they have moments where
they can be great i don't know if they
can be consistent
and in the playoffs you're going to have
to win
usually one ugly game you're gonna have
to win um
like probably a game on the road and you
know are they capable of doing that
you know somebody's gonna win the east
if the cowboys with all those weapons if
the defense gets healthy and andy dalton
plays
like andy dalton did in cincinnati are
the cowboys
capable of going to the super bowl as
crazy as that may sound
seattle obviously can go to the super
bowl new orleans
are you all in on tampa bay uh you know
so that's just the nfc where you go
okay i got a pretty good hand i don't
know what's happening with green bay now
because prior to yesterday green bay
would have been in the conversation
now are they still in the conversation
uh you know but it's referendum monday
so that's why
there's always this overreaction one way
or another well i guess
with you saying uh what you've just said
dp i
i jotted down eight teams that i think
could as we're sitting here right now
through six weeks
win a super bowl and um i i put down
tampa seattle tennessee
pittsburgh kansas city green bay
baltimore and buffalo i'm going to
include buffalo in that mix
and then i guess in your second tier
that you're making me sort of get a
little hitch in my giddy up
i've put san francisco rams dallas
chicago
new orleans with i guess the outside
shots going to arizona
just in case they get in and just catch
fire
and then that may be about
it for me new england maybe if if
they're if they can catch fire and show
something that came out of nowhere uh
yesterday that could be avoided
you know when did we start with this i
need to have a declarative
statement on monday morning and i'm not
just talking about the media
but can you remember when it started
that it felt like i got to tell you what
i think
is really happening you know like oh i
knew it green bay
you know they're not going to be content
aaron rodgers
yep well you know now he's not an mvp
when did we start doing this where we
had this referendum where we had to give
you a declarative statement of
i know exactly how good the steelers are
today i know exactly how good the browns
are today
when in reality i always say i gotta
wait until probably
seven or eight games in i like to wait
till the end of october
then i get a true scent now we don't get
that luxury because people want
our opinions now but i don't remember
doing this
when i was younger i don't even remember
doing it when i was at espn where i go
yep i got that figured out i gotta have
an opinion like we're handing out the
mvp in september
i never remember doing that either so i
guess maybe
uh maybe when there was a split screen
and a topic bar at the bottom of the
screen and television shows like that
started coming out
you know where there's two people and uh
maybe
i i take the i take the uh one side of
the argument you take the other side of
the argument we just start yelling at
each other
could have that it could be one of those
moments but do you think this is pardon
the interruption
no do you think it started with mike and
tony no
no i don't i will they're always the
exception to that rule
i think personally because there was you
know
the the the five good minutes there's
always that's a different
i don't know i always think that that's
the outlier
dan don't you i don't think that there's
an agenda when they start
their show yeah i you know some of the
other shows have an agenda when they
start but i
i don't think michael and tony are are
doing something
to kind of you know
titillate and let's go with you know
polar opposites and
i'm always amazed they have two guys who
are together all the time but they never
agree on anything
with some of these shows like you're
going and here's the topic
uh you know the sun is out today
yeah yeah but yeah but you know what i
i'm going to get a burn and i don't have
sunblock on and i gotta wear sunglasses
whereas the other person says oh this is
great to go out and feel the sunshine no
matter what comes up
it feels like they're always going to
disagree dan i think that's outrageous
[Laughter]
it's outrageous hold on a second i
couldn't go to work every day
here's here's my favorite word here's
the word disgrace
that's the one that's the next level
that's a disgrace
dan what you just said it's just it's a
total disgrace
right yeah yeah i i'm i'm glad that we
didn't have this
when when i was at the mothership you
know we didn't have this combative back
and forth
where you had people who had to have you
know you got to have your side
and then you kind of uh get armed with
stats to be able to
fend off the uh the other guy and while
it can be entertaining it would it would
be
tiring every day to go okay who don't i
like today
or who do i like today and somebody's
doing research for me
dan patrick here on the rich i don't
think we'd go in this direction but i i
i love this conversation quite honestly
uh to be honest with you dan
towards the end of my tenure at
sportscenter
became less a show about what happened
and more about arguing about why
it happened and that's why shows like
van pelt are the total outlier and
are so popular and and that's why i
think highlight shows
are too damn extinct
right now dan what do you think about
that
well how would you program then
highlight shows now
just show the highlights and have fun
with it
just like they were when you know i was
watching you and ko
before i joined in 96 and what i did
with stuart
to 2003 and and uh you know
um what we see the fastest three minutes
of the schwamm doing it still at
halftime tonight which
i i get a kick out of i don't know if
maybe i'm on the back end
i uh you know of of on the back nine i
don't know
but i i just still think people just
still wanna and sit back and enjoy
and watch what happened you know
but then why don't these executives do
that right why don't they
say is this working or not working
and then what do you you know what makes
uh skip and shannon and and stephen a
and max like they they stand out
not everybody can do that should do that
the same with pardon the interruption
not everybody can or should do that
that's where i think you counter program
don't try to be like that that you know
there's
it feels like that formula still works
at espn if you have knowledgeable people
doing the highlights
with enthusiasm you have an analyst who
comes in
and you don't yell at people you just
talk to people
and have fun with it that would probably
be my approach to it
you know the only i guess it's not a
negative but
we know the outcome chances are we've
seen the highlights when we watch these
shows
whereas before when we were in the mid
90s
you were tuning in because you didn't
know how a game ended it was a great
luxury for us to have
i just think you have to realize your
audience probably knows what's going on
therefore treat it as that
now how do you spin this forward and
uh i guess give your audience something
that's entertaining
but in a in a different way then let's
just yell at one another
dan patrick here on the rich eisen show
pleased again that uh this show follows
dan's
show every single day on nbc sports on
peacock as well as serious channel
uh sirius xm channel 211.
so uh i i didn't even think we'd get off
of that on that because i asked you who
the best team is
in the nfl through almost six weeks
right here
um so i i guess do we do we
turn to the world series what is your
sense of how popular baseball is
dan and what you see every day with
phone lines lighting up and whatever
metrics you may have
about dodgers rays and things like that
dp
well i think the dodgers since were on
the flagship station for the dodgers in
los angeles on morning drive
and it's important you know it's a
dodger town too
i know we talk about the lakers but you
know it's a big deal for the dodgers
and this is a world series or bus so i
have to i have to
pay respects to it i i loved i picked
the raise in the dodgers to meet in the
world series so i'm
i i've watched a lot and i bought into
the depth of the pitching stamp
certainly with tampa and i've enjoyed it
i know we get caught up in ratings is
anybody watching this
i i want to talk about things that i
enjoy watching or
talking about i don't feel like i have
to check a box and go um
did i mention uh dak prescott's contract
today
oh i got to bring that up today you know
or hey what about lebron
uh what about lebron i don't know let's
bring up something about lebron
i just if the story's there and it's
entertaining
then i bring it up if not i i don't
try to you know do something out of the
ordinary or go out of my way to you know
just check the box there but
i've enjoyed it i'll watch the world
series and
i never worried about ratings ever
i never cared about ratings even when i
was doing a show
or radio show or tv i just watch i just
do it because one day somebody taps you
on the shoulder and says
hey patrick come here uh bring your
playbook
and and that'll be it but until then
i just enjoy it i mean this is what i
why i got into it is
because i enjoy watching something i'll
watch football tonight both of those
games
uh i watched the jets against the
dolphins yesterday
uh i watched you know clemson against
georgia tech
uh syracuse against liberty like this is
what i get paid to do this and if
there's a story that's there we get to
share it with our audience then great or
get a guest on that you share with your
audience
that's what's fun i mean it's it's
reciprocated
they listen they trust they let you in
your home or their home their car
and you're doing the same thing so i
just say let's
share in it trust me when i say we're
going to talk about this we're going to
have a guest on that you may not know
then it's fun uh or a topic and what is
our approach to that topic that makes it
different than somebody else
those are the challenges we have every
day but those are great challenges to
have no doubt about it dp
uh so that one time where sportscenter
created a commercial where i was told to
get my playbook and wound up at james k
polk high school um that wasn't real
dan is that what you're saying because
as you know i was very upset about
no no that was real you know that was
that because i wound up i wound up
on a sports center commercial talking
about james k polk spirit
i told that story the other day on my
twitter feed and um
it just lit up about you pulling me
aside when i got
that assignment and i was upset about it
i didn't want to do the commercial
yeah and you basically sat me down and
told me to suck it up that
that they were going to me for my
comedic talents not by sending me down
to the minors dan
i remember that day do you yeah
and i understood what you were saying
because your
the audience you think is under the
impression that hey i'm not good enough
to stay up here
yeah and but but if it became funny
because
you were obviously good enough it's just
we had to send somebody down
and then you you know they wanted you to
buy beer for them
and if it just worked because of your
delivery and i i said
you if you didn't do that commercial
right
i i mean that's one of the iconic
commercials that we ever did for
sportscenter
in my opinion that's one of the top 10
to 15 commercials that we ever did
because of what it was and and what it
stood for and it still
it still holds up now even when you
watch it
you can't help but laugh well because
people are
you know still trying to get beer bought
for him by somebody older i guess
what was your favorite what was your
favorite that you were in
that you did which one was that was that
grant hill and the piano
and when he was playing the piano in the
lobby and you kind of tipped him and
walked out i mean what was what's yours
dp
no it was when oberman and i were
putting on our makeup in the bathroom
because that was real that was real that
was real that's like a real moment
because there was no makeup
artists provided to on-air sportscenter
anchors at the time
i remember that yeah they're making a
couple hundred million
each year but they couldn't afford a
makeup artist for us and we had to go in
we had no professional training and
we're
yeah we put our makeup on the way
joaquin phoenix did in the joker
no clue
we had no idea what we were looking like
but it was okay i borrowed makeup from
my wife and then
so we're in there putting makeup on and
we're talking about
tough guys in hockey so just the whole
juxtaposition of
we're putting on makeup while we're
talking about tough guys in hockey and
that was the sensibility that wyden
kennedy had
like they they truly had a magical touch
with that there's so many great
commercials but that's probably my
favorite just because
it was true that we put our makeup on
every night
and uh that's usually the first time
keith and i would
kind of talk about the day and then we
you know 15 minutes later we were on the
air on sportscenter
there was one i saw the other day that i
honestly forgot i was in
i'll be honest with you dan and um i
guess it was the one where
joe montana's ring got lost in the soup
that was served to us
in the um in the cafeteria and i think
we are like stuart you and i were in it
i think van pelt as well where we found
that ring is there
have you seen have you seen an ad where
you forgot you were in it has that ever
happened to you
too that one did and i
it's in my bowl of soup that i find
montana's
ring yeah he's lost one of his super
bowl rings
so i'm watching it um and it was montana
posted that
and that's right somebody said hey
montana posted this video
and i go and like i don't know what it's
about and then i realized
it was the commercial that i'm in where
i find his super bowl in my soup
and uh and then at the end you know
stuart
uh takes it out of the soup when it's
all said and done but
i forgot we did so many of those because
people didn't realize we would go into
work
and we still had to do sportscenter that
night and you'd go in at eight or nine
in the morning
shoot two maybe three of those
commercials
and then you would start your normal day
and
you know we didn't get paid anything you
didn't get days off to do these things
it was like
whoever was there at sportscenter they
kind of said oh hey
do you want to be in this commercial
like when the wrestlers the professional
wrestlers came in
i i forgot you know they're like hey the
wrestlers are here and i go
oh okay and then i don't even know i'm
in the commercial and they go
yeah they're gonna like have you up
against the wall in uh
in you know one of the uh stairwells and
i go
okay so i got the undertaker or triple h
with his forearm up against my throat
and then
i get done with that and then i have to
go write sportscenter like that was just
a normal day
there and you know you forget about how
many we did
it's amazing dp i appreciate the call i
appreciate everything as you know
um and uh so just to recap we just went
down memory lane
uh we both feel very lucky to have the
shows that we have
and you think the best team in the nfl
through six weeks is baltimore which is
an outrage and a disgrace
correct did i get that all correct you
got that all right
yeah yes yep okay you did your job
tell the boys i said hello there rich
good buddy
be good same to you samia that's stan
patrick hosting the dan patrick show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here